COLT MCANLIS: The future
of Cloud is now at Next.
RETO MEIER: But not everyone
can be there in person
to get new ideas, learn
from industry experts,
and engage with their peers.
COLT MCANLIS: I'm Colt McAnlis.
RETO MEIER: And I'm Reto Meier.
COLT MCANLIS: And
together we'll watch
every one of over 200 sessions
on Google Cloud Platform.
RETO MEIER: 200 sessions?
COLT MCANLIS: Yes,
over 200 sessions
on Google Cloud Platform,
G Suites, Maps, devices,
and more.
RETO MEIER: Wait.
And more?
That's like--
COLT MCANLIS: 8.3.
RETO MEIER: That's
more than eight days
of continuous sessions.
COLT MCANLIS: Yes, which is
why we will watch them all
and create bite-sized videos
highlighting some of the most
amazing content just for you.
RETO MEIER: Have we
really thought about this?
COLT MCANLIS: So join me--
RETO MEIER: And me?
COLT MCANLIS: As we take you on
an exclusive tasting of Google
Cloud Next, distilling
200 hours of Cloud content
into exquisite concentrate.
If you've liked this
Next recap, check out
the other videos in the
playlist, which should be here?
Here?
Down more?
Right there?
OK.
Click there.